hey youtubers it's Charlie and the
moment has finally come we finally got a
trailer for Game of Thrones Season 4 we
also learned that episode 1 is going to
air on April 6 which is pretty close to
1 season 3 premiered if you haven't seen
any my Game of Thrones Season 4 videos
before they're basically changing a lot
of the plot of season 4 to be different
from what happens in the books so
basically combining you know books 3 4 &
5 together to make season 4 this video
will be a breakdown of the trailer and
all the images and scenes that we see in
it so I'll try to keep out spoilers for
things that do not happen in the trailer
just a heads up - I'm going to be doing
some special bonus Game of Thrones
videos each week in addition to my you
know weekly episode reviews if you've
been watching my Sherlock videos it's
going to be kind of like that like
there'll be a review the night of then
the next day will be a Q&A video and
then I'll be doing a contest video -
I'll have a link to that at the end of
the description so you can learn all
about it be sure to subscribe to get
everything though because it's going to
be a lot of fun alright so time for
dragons here we go number one
a dragon shadow over King's Landing the
trailer opens to a shot of a dragon
flying over King's Landing we just see
the shadow but it does kind of imply
that there is a dragon that has left the
east and come to Westeros if that ends
up being true that it would be a huge
departure from canon because where
things are in the books right now none
of the dragons have left the east - look
at the wingspan of that dragon it's huge
it's almost like they're jumping forward
in the story several months the Dragons
grow very fast in the books but drogon
the biggest isn't this large until dance
with dragons so soon that season 4 will
include aspects of book 5 3 the purple
wedding feast this is the red wedding
level event of season 4 I won't spoil
what happens but the voiceover from
Jamie talks about how that people love
their king which is a play on the notion
that everyone basically wants Joffrey
dead the war that they're talking about
is the war against Stannis and
Blackwater in reality it was actually
Tyrion that saved the city for a feast
for crows The Crow is very symbolic to A
Song of Ice and Fire
but visually in the trailer it's a
reference to book for a feast for crows
it's just the idea that the dead are
starting to pile up everywhere number 5
Daenerys and her friends own marched
their army to marine number 6 the
charger barreling down Daenerys is
possibly one of the sons of the harpy
number 7 the new Daario the actor
playing Daario was recast and this is
the first shot of him we get
he's actually really small so you can
barely see him but he's been up to cast
regular for season five much to the
chagrin of sir friendzone number eight
the slaves of marine remember last
season Daenerys had dedicated her army
to abolishing slavery in the major
cities these are the next people that
she's going to try and save number nine
Stannis and Melisandre make ready for
the wall remember last season during the
finale Stannis pledged to take his
forces to fight the White Walkers number
10 Tyrion in peril this season is a big
turning point for Tyrion in that look on
his face is the I think everyone's
trying to kill me face number 11 Jamie
tries to end the siege of Riverrun even
after the red wedding the blackfish is
still alive and super pissed that his
entire family was murdered
number 12 Stannis and his army actually
sailing to Eastwatch that's the
easternmost part of the wall thirteen
sir friends own counsels Daenerys about
her new role Marine she wants to get rid
of slavery but involves making a deal
with the devil so to speak the problem
is is that she can't solve all of her
problems with dragons 14 the sons of the
harpy attack once Daenerys occupies
marine the fighting doesn't end the sons
of the harpy the mercenary group start
fighting a shadow war against her
unsullied and the other mercenary she
comes to rely on in the books they're
called the shape eights in the Friedmann
number 15 this is his arse o lauric he's
a very powerful person to marine that
Dany has to decide whether or not to
marry to end the shadow war and abolish
slavery he controls both the sons of the
harpy and the slave trade number 16
Danny's voiceover she's talking about
keeping the sons of the harpy the option
of either accepting that she's
abolishing slavery or dying
number 17 this is Jamie wielding
Oathkeeper it was one of the new
Valyrian blades made by melting down ice
Eddard Starks huge two-handed great
sword it's the closest thing to a
lightsaber in A Song of Ice and Fire
number 18 Tyrion on trial this is Tyrion
facing judgment after the events of the
purple wedding feast which I will not
utter here let's just say he's in deep
[ __ ] number 19 Tyrion in jail as you can
guess he gets thrown in jail after the
purple wedding feast this is before the
trial the trailer is actually jumping
back and forth in time number 20 the red
Viper this is our first real shot of
Pedro Pascal as the red Viper 21 he
great is back she's super pissed and the
wildlings have reached the Nights Watch
there may
last season was to take the night's
watch from the other side of the wall
from the Nights Watch side and open the
gates so that Mance Rayder could bring
his army of wildlings through as you can
see 22 Jon Snow prepares the Nights
Watch to fight the wildling raiding
party 23 this is one of manses giants
that we saw pounding posts into the
ground with their bare hands you can't
tell from the scale here but those gates
are huge 24-yard Greyjoy takes her
forces to look for Theon in the books
her name was Asha but they just changed
it for the show
25 Jaime gets fitted for his golden hand
seriously it's a hand made out of gold
26 this is Cersei Post purple wedding 27
this is one of the Nights Watch brothers
offering up his baby to the children of
the forest it's the same thing that old
Craster was going to do with Gilley's
baby because it was a boy 28 Arya starts
to travel east 29 Littlefinger starts to
scramble post purple wedding 30 the red
Viper tries to get help from Tyrion and
learning the truth about his sister the
murdered wife of Rhaegar Targaryen 31
this is the epic fight between the red
Viper and the mountain the mountain was
recast again just to make him look even
bigger and even scarier 32 this is
Joffrey and Margaery at the actual
purple wedding ceremony it's also one of
the biggest scenes that they've filmed
on the show since the season 1 premiere
33 Jaime with his new golden hand takes
over the gold cloaks Brienne has really
rubbed off on him so he's trying to be
honorable now 34 rewind a bunch real
quick this scene is actually between
Jaime and Cersei right after he gets
back at the end of season 3 before he
gets the golden hand chronologically
it's probably something that happens
during episode 135 the Nights Watch
prepare for the big battle with the
wildlings which you can also see
attacking in this next scene 36 more
from the purple wedding feast notice
that bowl that the servant is carrying
it's very very important 37 looks like
Theon made it out of the dungeon
minus a few body parts the characters
transformation is very different from
what it is in the books
38 this is the first good shot of the
new actor playing the mountain yes he is
very big 39 this is Melisandre talking
to Gilly at the wall number 40
this is Jane Poole who the Lannisters
married to Ramsay snow she's pretending
to be Arya Stark and they're at
winterfell Ramsey snow is basically made
ruler there so they're probably in edit
starts bedroom right now 41 this is
Sansa in the Airy Littlefinger takes her
there after the events of the purple
wedding remember Kaitlyn's sister is
ruler there and she is totally nutters
42 re in the hound are still in the
Riverlands this scene actually happens
before the first shot we saw her earlier
in the trailer when she wasn't with the
Hound 43 Daenerys addressing the newly
freed slaves from yoon kye this actually
happens right after the events of the
season 3 finale so this is also probably
something from that first episode 44
Tyrion gets thrown in the black cells
that's where they threw Eddard Stark
before he was beheaded in season 1 and
Tyrion actually threw maester pycelle
there during season 2 it's basically the
worst place you can get thrown in in
King's Landing 45 and last one notice
the yellow banner
this is Stannis's army racing to help
the Nights Watch fight the wildlings
looks like they get there just in time
I'll say that based on this trailer the
things that I'm looking forward to most
are one the purple wedding and two that
battle with the wildlings let me know in
the comments though you know based on
this what are you most excited to see
the trailer also kind of implies that we
will see a full-sized dragon but I'm
gonna wait to believe that until I see
it so like I said I'm going to be doing
special Game of Thrones videos for each
episode whenever it comes back be sure
to subscribe to get everything
they'll be q and A's there'll be a
contest I'll be giving away stuff every
week it'll be a lot of fun right now you
can click here to learn about that
special contest it's called kill list
and you can click here to get all of my
Game of Thrones Season 4 previews I try
to do one for all the main characters
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you